vous intriguez par l'idée de voir ces
ces deux femmes dans le même lit et
quand vous en parlez à votre mère elle
vous dit que c'est parce qu'il y a pas
de place
pourtant vous connaissez tout le monde
vous avez 27 ans vous êtes journaliste
si vous publiez chez Leduc édition j'ai
deux mamans c'est un secret en histoire
commence en 1981 vous avez 3 ans votre
maman quitte votre papa pour une femme
très vite on vous dit que la dame est
votre tente et votre mère vous dites tu
sais c'est comme ma sœur
oh là prenez note moi
mais votre père meurtrie par son divorce
et par le fait de voir une femme auprès
de sa femme comment sa balancer à
l'époque vous avez même pas 6 ans il
vous dit tu sais c'est à cause de Tata
que papa et maman se sont séparés c'est
une méchante femme elle m'a volé ma
fille
il veut la tuer il la traite de gouinas
vous réagissez comment vous à ce
moment-là je le crois pas en fait
ma mère ne me disant pas l'autre version
de la réalité je le crois pas je pense
qu'il est mal qu'il est dans la douleur
et puis quand on est enfant on a une
certaine loyauté envers ses parents donc
je le juge pas
vous sentez quand même qu'il y a quelque
chose qui cloche à la maison vous êtes
intriguez par l'idée de voir si ces deux
femmes dans le même lit et quand vous en
parlez à votre mère elle vous dit que
c'est parce qu'il y a pas de place
c'est en fait j'ai vécu
quasi toute ma vie jusqu'à mes 20 ans
avec elle d'eux et les choses n'ont
jamais été nommées parce que parce que
je l'ai compris plus tard ma mère ne
pouvait pas se vivre comme tel en fait
donc elle pouvait pas me le dire à moi
votre vie devient un énorme mensonge
vous croyez votre mère quand elle vous
dit qu'elle va se marier qu'en fait
c'est une situation comme ça provisoire
que elle va retrouver un homme et ça
dure comme ça ça dure jusqu'à vos 15 ans
jusqu'à un choc énorme qu'on peut dire
le choc de votre vie en tous les cas
vous tombez sur une lettre écrite par
votre temps enfin par cette tente en
tous les cas en 1980 un an avant la
séparation de vos parents il y avait
quoi dans cette lettre c'était une
lettre d'amour mais c'était une lettre
explicite qui qui m'a donné la preuve
irréfutable que qu'elles étaient un
couple qu'elles étaient ensemble
là où vous découvrez que votre mère vous
ment depuis 10 ans
ouais je le prends comme un très gros
choc comme une trahison mais c'est vrai
que après on devient adulte et on
comprend on comprend que c'était pas un
mensonge
comment dire elle l'a pas faits
sciemment c'est elle a fait ce qu'elle a
pu
alors au moment où vous trouvez cette
lettre votre mère a un accident de
voiture s'est étonnant au moment précis
une demi-heure après ma tante m'appelle
et me dit elle a eu un accident alors
quand vous apprenez ça vous vous
rassurez
en couchant avec votre petite amie un
jour votre mère découvre dans votre sac
des plaquettes de pilule
elle vous dit tu m'as menti et vous lui
dites toi aussi
j'essaye de parler avec elle c'est vrai
que j'ai pas pu tout de suite c'est
difficile de parler de la sexualité de
ses parents on devrait pas et puis et
puis et puis elle se met à pleurer et
c'est totalement impossible pour moi de
parler je pense que j'ai raté une
occasion à ce moment-là parce que elle
aurait peut-être pu
commencer à avoir des insomnies vous
demandez si plus tard vous serez pas
vous-même homosexuel et vous commencez
une thérapie à 18 ans dans ce livre et
un petit peu l'aboutissement d'une
certaine façon complètement disons je
vous dis j'ai réglé les problèmes par
rapport à moi mais ce dialogue avec ma
mère j'ai envie de la voir je n'arrive
pas à l'avoir alors évidemment ce livre
s'appelle j'ai deux mamans c'est un
secret chez le duc édition donc
aujourd'hui c'est plus un secret comment
votre mère a réagi la lecture du livre
alors j'avais parlé du projet il y a
quelques mois elle était pas contre mais
c'est vrai qu'à la lecture ça je pense
que ça a été un gros choc pour elle et
pour l'instant c'est assez difficile
mais je pense qu'il nous faut du temps
fera son œuvre mais les choses sont là
les choses sont dites c'est pas un livre
j'ai aucune demande de réparation par
rapport à tout ça mais c'est une demande
de reconnaissance et votre temps entre
guillemets la réagi comment mais au
début bien et puis et puis elle se range
plutôt derrière la vie de ma mère donc
c'est la même réaction c'est difficile
pour l'instant le dialogue est pas
encore commencé j'ai pas rétabli quoi
malgré le livre malgré le livre mais je
pense que c'est très dur de de se voir
dans un livre c'est vrai que moi je
c'est quelque part un petit peu violent
mais je le fais je l'ai fait aussi pour
moi parce que c'est aussi ma vie et je
pense qu'il faut du temps
alors ce livre bon c'est un témoignage
c'est votre témoignage mais vous l'avez
prolongé par une enquête auprès
d'enfants élevé par des couples
homosexuels il y en a quand même 100000
aujourd'hui en France c'est une
fourchette basse puisque évidemment des
tas de famille et des teint d'enfants
qui se prononce pas donc c'est vraiment
une fourchette très basse et tout tout
le propos du livre c'est de dire
les gens savent pas qu'il y a autant
d'enfants dans ce cas là et regardez
nous prenez nous en compte alors il y a
pas d'associations d'enfants de parents
gay et vous c'est le fait d'avoir fait
votre témoignage finalement qui vous a
donné beaucoup de crédibilité auprès de
ces gens là c'est à dire que finalement
vous l'ayant fait c'était facile pour
eux d'en parler exactement et c'est très
étonnant ce que je au début je pensais
trouver les gens par association et j'ai
vraiment trouvé quasiment tout le monde
par bouche à oreille à partir du moment
où j'ai commencé à parler de ce projet
de livre il y avait une amie d'une amie
la copine une copine qui connaissait un
tel et puis ça s'est fait vraiment
les enfants du
[Rires]
[Musique]
de crier sur le volet et j'ai eu la
chance de d'avoir des amis assez
délicats qui me posait pas la question
qui était pas normale mais c'est très
étonnant parce que j'ai revu des amis
récemment qui me connaissent de cette
époque là et elle m'ont dit on savait
que cette femme était homosexuelle
puisque physiquement elle ressemble à
une homosexuelle mais jamais on s'est
dit que ta mère était avec donc je pense
que c'est aussi c'est pas c'est pas les
gens savent mais ils ont pas non plus
envie de voir des choses qui les
dérangent ou qui comprennent pas et et
les cheveux courts elle fumait la pipe
elle avait des tatouages non justement
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas gazon
maudit mais elle est elle est pas
féminine quoi enfin juré les gens les
gens qui savent ce qu'est une homosexuel
la définition justement vous dites le
problème c'est le regard des autres
parce que finalement quand on va à
l'école il y a deux cas soit en
revendique la marginalité de ses parents
et on s'en sert comme d'une provocation
soit on s'enferme dans le mensonge et
finalement c'était un petit peu
l'enfermement dans le mensonge je me
suis retranché derrière le fait que
j'étais une enfant de divorcée enfin
c'est tout et puis c'est vrai quand on
me demandait enfin ceux que je n'amenais
pas chez moi les amis que je n'avais pas
chez moi je disais que ma mère n'avait
pas refait sa vie
alors conclusion de votre enquête vous
dites les familles homoparentales sont
atypiques mais normal et font des
enfants normaux c'est vraiment le tout
le ce qui est très important c'est
arrêter de prendre ses enfants là pour
des enfants anormaux pour pour des
enfants qui vont devenir eux-mêmes
homosexuels parce que c'est pas
forcément le cas et sa déstructure pas
l'enfant le ski des structures c'est ce
que ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure c'est
c'est le mensonge c'est le non dit c'est
mais moi j'ai croisé que des familles
hyper stables ou les couples sont là
depuis 20 ans j'ai vraiment pas croisé
de de cas sociaux quoi des cas marginaux
certes mais pas mais pas l'homosexualité
comme une maladie les enfants les ont
élevé par les homosexuels peuvent avoir
une vie complètement normale oui la
réponse que je fais tout le temps
maintenant c'est est-ce que les
homosexuels ont eu des parents
homosexuels c'est d'une logique
implacable en tous les cas vous êtes la
première en parler aussi ouvertement et
à écrire là-dessus
j'étais là dessus je pense que ça peut
faire avancer les choses
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
inarritube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu